Oh boring shift too much dad it's about  punctual boys crosstown just got two  more bodies he said both had some kind  of mark on there now three reign and  victims at the times of death of minutes  apart bodies of miles mark has that  worked  hello Thomas what'd you say is this  where it happens  today marks the nine year anniversary of  the Market Street murders and a still  unidentified suspect detective Walker  yes hello we need to happen again  you guys gotta see this to APD it seems  woman nice to see you again it's 25 five  training nine years later she's back she  is priority number one for all law  enforcement agencies you have to stop  chasing these and doing all this for a  reason  [Music]  [Music]  you have no idea what's coming  if you kill me now the world as you know  it will end  [Music]